hey guys I'm just middle it is the
second of January and you're joining me
proud first GSU's of 2014 which means we
can finally stop talking about how much
the now current-gen consoles are selling
that is after this post story about just
that sorry it turns out that in the UK
the ps4 has outsold the xbox one by a
hundred and sixty-six thousand units
unsurprisingly GTA 5 grabbed a spot for
best selling game the stats recorded by
the entertainment retailers association
show that the driving and shooting
extravaganza grabbed the first place
spot by selling 3.67 million units in
the UK on a worldwide basis as far as
the console war goes the two now current
gen offerings from Microsoft and Sony up
basically neck and neck were you
expecting a landslide victory for one
console or the other let me know we have
some news about World of Warcraft which
barely ever happens and it's about micro
transactions which is sure to serve warm
fuzzy feelings specifically Blizzard are
already given you one free character
upgrade to take your meager warrior to
level 90 for free alongside the warlords
of Draenor expansion but the publisher
wants to know how much you'd pay for a
second less free character upgrade Wow
already features microtransaction
options surrounding name changes and
character appearance alterations as well
as in game pets mouths and helms
blizzard have said they weren't
necessarily to see you the move to
integrate a paid character upgrade but
it's suggested that for the time poor
player this could be a good option of
apps for the time poor player don't play
a game like World of Warcraft let me
know what you think of the potential
feature and how much would you pay for a
character upgrade according to
Metacritic a lot of us were mistaken in
thinking that 2013 game offerings were
pretty sweet since apparently
statistically they were kind of average
the review aggregator has reported that
2013 so the fewest amount of 90 plus
scoring games in the entirety of the
xbox 360 and ps3 lifespan in fact there
was seven yeah only seven bc mobile and
handheld
titles when added to the list boosts the
number to an equally unimpressive 1290
plus scoring titles the specific console
devotees ps3 releases averaged 17.1
while ps4 games grabbed a slightly
better 73.4 xbox 360 games averaged out
of 60 6.9 while xbox one releases are
sitting at around 67.7 in terms of
exclusive games the PC one out with 45
games that aggregated 75 for hire this
is six aside what platform had your
favorite game selection of last year you
can let me know in the comments down
below or on my twitter where i'm at just
mcdonald in terms of free stuff if you
feel like going in the draw to
potentially win a razor blade laptop you
can do so by heading over to our
facebook page right now that's most of
the things worth knowing about from
today but if you've been in the gaming
news dark then you can check out my top
5 of stories worth knowing about from
the holiday period and just McDonald and
I will catch you again soon